hello reject nation my name is sally lamonico
and i am doing videos on this channel again
uh if you're new here hi you can call me
salamander if you want to i do have an
instagram sally lamonico and a youtube channel of
myself so you can go ahead and go and subscribe
to that but the more important channel right now
is the real rejects because we are doing a marvel
movie marathon i am so excited i am still on
phase one this is the second video in the series
i am watching the incredible hulk for the first
time i've never seen it surprise me uh the only
thing i do know about the incredible hulk is that
there's a roller coaster in orlando at universal's
islands of adventure marvel superhero island that
was a mouthful it's freaking dope and i've been
on it many times it's amazing i just went there
actually and if you'd like a tour of it i have
a video on my channel about it and hopefully by
the time this video comes out it's on there go
ahead and click subscribe on this channel this
is a series so if you want to keep up with my
movie reactions for the marvel cinematic
universe please hit that notification bell
and you'll be notified when i'm posting next
and you'll also be notified when greg and john
put up their trailer reactions and reviews and
movie reviews and just everything if you love
cinema please subscribe to this
channel because we will love you
that sounded weird um also you know go ahead
and hit a like and you want to know why because
i spent a really long time working on my
eyeshadow i mean look at it it's incredible
like the incredible hulk so um also if
you would like to see a full reaction
aka you can sit and watch the whole entire movie
with me so you can go to patreon.com there rejects
become a patron of the real rejects and you
can watch the full movie with me and it's a
good time and lastly thanks to prepper for editing
together all of the highlights for this video i am
incredibly happy for that thank you guys
anyway let the marvel movie marathon commence
wait wait wait wait i thought i thought
it was mark ruffalo where's mark ruffalo
oh my god
green sasquatch
i thought he'd have green eyes
oh jeez
i'm triggered
jeez what is this high school bro like for real
better not be any vampires around
oh
that's lucky
okay
it's like a really rich
oh no that looks like paint guys come on
ew oh my god
is that supposed to be like
a cure for him or something
here's something a bit more interesting it's
a possible gamma sickness milwaukee stan the
man drank one of those guarana sodas guess it
had a little more kick than he was no stan no
target's on the move don't kill the dog
i hope he dies
she's like wait where are you going
why is he wearing a red hoodie
like that just stands out so stupid
you're out
oh
excuse you those aren't
birds you could have walked
how rude
this feels like a horror movie
yikes
he just casually walks away
yeah like that's gonna do anything
i love how bullets are like mosquitoes
to him he's just like ugh get away
i threw up a forklift truck like
it was a softball well it's gone
well if bannon knows what it is okay they don't
know it's him i was ben you have to explain
that statement
that was the most honest reaction like
you have to explain like i would have been
like yeah you need to explain a little more
why doesn't the military just use him
i guess he doesn't want to be used but
oh you did not just do that who would write that
thank you jesus he thought he was working on
radiation resistance i would never have told him
what the project really was but he was so sure of
what he was on to that he tested it on himself
and something just like the green goblin right
she's alive
she moved on bro what can they do to help you
i could use a bed for a few nights well
you can have the spare room upstairs
that'd be so great there's um there's one other
thing sorry i don't know why that made me laugh
there's
i felt that
why don't you just say hi
what's your freaking deal
you're gonna torture this poor girl again
i would have honked and
scared the [__] out of him
again with the heels on the grates what is this
there's no way your heels
wouldn't go through oh you
saw you saw it you saw it her heel went through
go with her and of course she's
wearing a white shirt in the rain guys
written by a dude first sign of any side effect we
stop and you're off team until you straighten out
you'll get two separate infusions one into
the deep muscle one under the bone marrow
i don't want to see that just cut away thank you
i hated that noise
what they're here ready look at me look at me you
have to go far away from me as you
can don't argue with me just go go
oh
stop
girl
what you can't see this
he's gonna have to [__] out the usb
hit her back here
oh good shot man
get her in the tank
oh
get her and why is she still out in the open
like that like you're her dad get her to safety
move him toward the cannons
oh my god
stop shooting him it doesn't do anything it's
just gonna ricochet and hit you in the head
is that all you got
sorry
he just kicks him oh god damn it
dude get away this is stressful
this is so stupid
um
get her out of the fumes oh my god this is
so this is making me mad i'm gonna turn to
the hulk right now you did the right thing
calling i need to know where they're going
should be an incredible danger
as long as she's with me from who
he protected her you almost killed her
it's a point of professional pride with me
that i can always tell when somebody's lying
then you are facts facts i know she'll help
him if she can and she's aiding a fugitive
and i can't help by anyone
again her father's a sociopath
so as the hulk i guess he can still be
caring it's got a heart like a machine
never seen anything like it outside of a racehorse
his villain origin story further
search for the mysterious hulk was
postponed by powerful thunderstorms
in the smoky mountain national forest
wait is ho it's hulk a word hulk means a large
boat so this dude just saw everything it was like
that's a hulk i'm i'm confused i can't
get too excited not even a little excited
okay
so if he ever gets horny he
turns into the whole imagine
there's a lot to explore with them talking
about it but what the aliases mr green and
mr blue have been added to the shield operations
database if he comes up for air we'll be waiting
yeah i'm not gonna use credit cards but i'm
gonna send an email so they can't trace us
dr ross i have someone who'd like to meet you okay
it's mr blue isn't it
mr green and he's wearing blue isn't he
dialysis machine will mix the
antidote to your blood so the
antidote will only take hold once
we've achieved the full reaction
just relax okay we are what a nice supportive
girl but i don't think she should be in there
chris look at me stay with me now do it now
she's brave because i would run
bruce bruce can you hear me it's okay you're
okay you can't breathe you're on top of him
we could get the no bell for this you don't
understand the power of this thing it is too
dangerous it cannot be controlled they don't
want the antidote they want to make it a weapon
you would have thought he would
have gone over this with him already
i feel like but you're being a
little paranoid don't you think
delayed reaction
get out
that was not necessary he was a freak accident
the goal is to do it better so banner's the only
she was just doing what you were i don't
know what you've got inside you already
the mixture could be an abomination
i didn't say i was unwilling
i just need informed consent
after being lifted off the ground
i just need consent i can fix this
what was that
what the heck was that
hello
uh yikes you think you can control no no not
could not control it but i don't know maybe aim it
land us there no no no keep
us high open the back door
you're gonna fall of the
surprise she's still alive betty i've gotta try
there you go
i like that shot that was a cool shot
hmm
he's got such tiny ears
they are lucky that thing didn't explode
she never dies i love it
he's like i'm tired
get out of the helicopter
what what was that he clapped and it went
away i mean good for you king but like what
stress
get out of the helicopter you've
had so much time any last words
ugh
get up through the heart
or decapitate him that works too
he almost blew you up let him oh my god
the necklace
snow steel beer i love that he's
either taking shots of like midori
or crown apple maybe like what a scene drink
ah roberto sorry i need to shut up i hear
you have an unusual problem you should talk
if i told you we were putting
a team together who's we
robert danny jr just like saved that ending
for me yes okay thoughts so my thoughts
sorry i heard something in my house and
got a little concerned so okay i have a
lot of thoughts about this movie so give me
a second um it was very entertaining i was
thoroughly entertained throughout the whole
movie in many different ways liv tyler is one
of my favorites like she's such an incredible
actress and i thought she did a really great
job in this movie i loved the action i thought the
action was fun very fun i loved the scene where um
they try to give him the the antidote like the
serum so his whole body is convulsing and going
back in between the hulk and himself bruce banner
i loved that sequence i thought that sequence was
super dope don't know why she was on top of him
though um that didn't make sense to me anyway
so that was really cool i did enjoy the fight
sequence at the end i thought that was dope like
i will say the beginning threw me off because i
felt like it was gonna be a completely different
type of movie based off like the first 30 minutes
i thought it was sick that they like started off
with the theme of like a monster movie i was
like whoa this is like a different take than
what i was expecting like it kind of mimicked
horror movies and monster movies in the beginning
when you first see him as the hulk that
was sick i kind of wish they would have
kept that style um and then it kind of like like
switched gears like a little bit halfway through
and then was more of a like action like eagle eye
type movie and then it went back to like superhero
maybe it was just the tone or the style just
changed too much for me that i couldn't it was
something about it like didn't flow as well i feel
like as iron man and stuff but i don't know it was
still entertaining like i enjoyed watching
it um i wasn't bored so you know what i mean
first of all i'm just gonna like talk about the
ending because i feel like a lot of times movies
are considered to be good or bad whether or not
the ending is good or bad like the ending has
a lot to do with people's decisions on whether or
not they like the movie i feel like now i can kind
of understand why people may not have liked this
movie i felt like it would have been more powerful
if he did kill the other hulk i thought the whole
point of how dangerous he was was that he couldn't
control it and he couldn't remember people when
he's in that state and so i thought it would
have been more powerful she was like no don't
and then he just freaking like snapped his neck
off like that would have been like whoa because
then that also would kind of signal to her like
i love him but like he's he's still dangerous like
very dangerous i get how sweet it was that she was
able to calm him down when he was in that state
and that he could remember her like it was cute
but there were just so many things about this
movie that i feel like didn't make sense to me
i felt like some of the acting like i don't know
if it was like the script or if it was acting
like i don't want to you know harp on anyone
in this movie but something about it just fell
off to me like some of the dialogue there was
something missing i don't know what it was
um i feel like edward norton did
like made a choice to be very
calm and subdued like given the character but
something about that didn't register with me
um on screen with some like i just it kind i feel
like it kind of messed with their chemistry a
little bit and some of the lines i don't know it
just made me laugh and like i don't think that it
was supposed to be funny i don't know there were
parts about this that kind of reminded me of like
a student film some of the plot points
and dialogue was like kind of reminded
me of that it was different i also don't know
that much about bruce banner in general and i
think that i still have a lot of questions
after watching it like where's mark ruffalo
anyway guys i hope you enjoyed my reaction again
please hit that subscribe button that like button
that helps the algorithm head over to the patreon
if you want to see my full reaction i do a lot of
this um also a quick shout out to my brother it is
his birthday today and his favorite color is green
and so i thought it was really funny that
it just so happened that i was scheduled to
film this today so happy birthday kyle and
look it's green that was the other thing too
so much green in this movie like everything was
green the fact that mr blue is wearing blue and
then he was like oh it just happened to be wearing
a green sweater like that was funny to me so many
things in this movie was green like everything
even the dude like shooting alcohol at the bar
it was green the soda was green everything was
green even the usb drive like lit up green and
it's like it just i don't know something about
everything being green like kept making me like
laugh a little bit like internally um i don't know
if i like let that on when i was watching it but
it was there was a lot of maybe that also took me
out of it a few times because like a lot of this
didn't really seem that like obviously it's not
based on reality at all but like it was very campy
it was very campy but um it was fun it was a
fun movie i had a fun time watching it i hope
you guys did as well and honestly robert dying
junior coming in at the end like that got me
to uh stop in my tracks and shut the f up he
brought me back you know what i mean like this
movie was a ride but he like brought me back to
like yes iron man it's here everything's fine it
made me excited i'm excited to watch the avengers
so please hit that notification bell again if
you want to see my next reaction and i hope you
guys have a wonderful night hulk smash okay bye